betting market selection models and a
political scientist who has correctly
predicted nine presidential elections
all say president Trump is headed for
victory in 2020 we will examine why then
Liz Warren gets wrecked on the radio the
world's tiniest baby ever is born Elton
John hates his own country and a
conservative writers so Rob Amari opens
up a major fight on the right I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so a political scientist and an American
University professor with a
extraordinarily good track record of
predicting presidential victories is
predicting that President Trump will win
in 2020 unless Democrats do this one
weird trick this one thing that he
suggests will help them to win in 2020
we will uncover what that is in just one
second but first let me tell you why I
look so good and feel so rested you
already know the answer to this it is
purple mattress my favorite bed that I
have ever slept on the purple mattress
will feel different than anything you've
ever experienced because it's not quite
an innerspring it's not quite a memory
foam it is this proprietary technology
developed by a rocket scientist what is
it I couldn't really tell you it feels
firm and soft at the same time I know
that sounds impossible when I first read
it I didn't believe it I almost didn't
even want to take the bed when it was
shipped to me then I tried it out for
one night and I became an evangelist for
purple mattress it is the greatest bed
I've ever slept in and you will love it
also what's really nice as we get into
summer is it breeds so unlike a lot of
other beds it doesn't get really really
hot it sort of sleeps cool and you know
you can throw on whatever blankets or
sheets that you want it is fabulous it
feels like you're floating zero-gravity
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund backed by a
ten year warranty free shipping and
returns free in-home set up and old
mattress removal you will love it
I've been telling you this for a long
time you have to try it right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to other great gifts they
offer site-wide how do you get that free
purple pillow you text knowles can de
wles to eight four eight eight eight the
only way to get this free pillow is to
Tex knowles canna wles
to eight four eight eight eight KO WLA s
to eight four eight and eight message
and data rates may apply so the good
news is President Trump is going to win
in 2020 according to not just one but
multiple election models from a lot of
people who have accurately predicted a
ton of presidential elections
that's a good news bad news is Democrats
have an opportunity to take that away
from him according at least to Allan
Lichtman who has correctly predicted
nine presidential elections his model
shows that Donald Trump is going to win
in 2020 unless the Democrats impeach so
this is a sort of interesting model
because what we've been told is that
Democrats impeaching President Trump
will destroy their chances in 2020
because the people will rally around
Trump they'll see it as a Democrat
overreach they'll see it as them trying
to overturn a presidential election
they'll rally to his side and give him
reelection this is the conventional
wisdom for the Clinton 96 election that
all of the Republican investigations
moves towards impeachment were
overstepping their bounds and the people
rallied you know they had they just
swept to the Republicans into the House
in 94 but then they rallied around Bill
Clinton in 1996 and gave him reelection
okay
the recent Allan Lichtman says that's
wrong is that impeachment happens in
1998 and what that gave to the Clinton
administration was the whiff of scandal
so as a result of this whiff of scandal
Al Gore lost the 2000 election because
people were sick of the ugliness and the
scandal of the Clinton administration
george w bush ran on restoring dignity
to the white house and so they kicked
that out war and they gave it to george
w bush possibly okay i see the argument
there the trouble is that the Trump
administration already has the whiff of
scandal it has the whiff of many
scandals actually they're all kind of
stupid scandals it's all a porn star
payment or he hired this guy who was no
good and then he this guy or he had a
real estate deal in the 80s I think
their scandals that people don't care
about but the mainstream media have
tried to make this the the scandal
administration meanwhile Barack Obama
who legitimately had serious political
scandals he politicized the IRS to go
after his political opponents Dinesh
D'Souza went to jail basically because
he made a mean documentary about Barack
Obama
he weaponized the DOJ under Loretta
Lynch he had the the Fast and Furious
scandal gun running under Eric Holder
into Mexico there were a lot of real
scandals under the Obama administration
obviously if you like your doctor you
can keep your doctor lying to the
American people
Donald Trump doesn't have that but he's
got in according to the mainstream media
in the popular culture more public
scandal than than Barack Obama did so I
don't really see that as being the issue
and it's not just Allan Lichtman
who has this this model though he has a
very good one the New York Times
unfortunately probably had a choke on it
as they were typing it out in their
article the other day the New York Times
showed three election models all of
which show that Trump is gonna win so
Steve Rattner writing in the New York
Times
he described the fare model this is for
Wraiths fare a professor at Yale ray
Fair found that the growth rates of GDP
and inflation have been the two most
important economic predictors in
presidential elections and obviously
President Trump is doing very well on on
those fronts in the economy is exploding
and especially after the sluggish awful
economy of Barack Obama things are
looking very good there on top of that
what Ray Fair found is that incumbency
is an important determinant of
presidential elections and President
Trump obviously is the incumbents who
has that going for him too when you add
those together very good shot the Donald
Trump gets reelected Mark Zandi who is
the chief economist at Moody's Analytics
looked at twelve different presidential
election models and Trump won all of
them it's important to note there's a
difference here between an election
model and election polls so polling is
just when you go out and you ask a bunch
of people who are you going to vote for
this guy or that guy a model is when you
take in all these sorts of various
factors perhaps that includes some
public polling it includes a lot of
economic data it includes foreign policy
data includes all of these things you
plug it all in together and a computer
then comes up with who is going to win
and Zandi lives Andy who's a serious guy
at Moody's looked at twelve different
models Trump wins all of them then
Donald Luskin at Trend macro analytics
or macro
rather looked at the electoral college
so he had a model that specifically
looked at the electoral college came to
the same conclusion Trump wins this is
very bad news for the left very good
news for the right why do people think
Trump won't win it's because he has a
relatively low approval rating that said
his approval rating somewhere before t
446 let's say it's still on par with or
higher than Barack Obama's at this point
in this presidency and don't forget
Barack Obama got reelected
now the other side of this is polling
looking at certain key states looking at
key demographics the president Trump is
going to have to win if he wants
reelection so the suburban white women
or certain areas of Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin etc still all of that
aside look at these models these models
have been fairly accurate and Trump wins
it so that's pretty good news I have
another theory on why President Trump is
likely to win in 2020 which is that
there isn't even one single candidate on
the other side who can beat him people
have been saying possibly Joe Biden you
got to remember Joe Biden's been hiding
out now for weeks he got his post
announcement bump and then he's hiding
away because he knows he's weak when he
goes out in public Bernie Sanders
possibly I don't really see that
happening at least Bernie stands for
something so maybe he can make a serious
play I don't really buy it Elizabeth
Warren's surging in the polls people
counted her out she was barely
registering in polls a few weeks ago now
she's up 8 percent 9 percent doing
pretty well
she's still nothing and this has not
been clearer than when she was on The
Breakfast Club this excellent radio show
yesterday morning and they called her
out for the eternal weakness of her
campaign what your family told you you
were Native American yeah
Charlemagne tells me I'm Dominican I
don't believe you are how long did you
all long it I could there was some
reports that said you were Native
American on your Texas Bar license and
that she said you were a Native American
or some documents when you are a
professor at Harvard like why'd you do
that so it's what I believe you know
that's like I said so what
for my family when you find out when did
you find out you want well you know it's
I'm not a person of color I'm not a
citizen of a tribe and tribal
citizenship is an important distinction
and not something I am so was there any
benefits in it no Boston Globe did a
full investigation it never affected
nothing about my family ever affected
any job I ever got um didn't get a
discount in college now it's kind of
like the original rates with those off a
little bit those all white woman
pretending to be black oh this is what I
learned from my family yeah yeah he was
just waiting talk about a really
masterful radio interview he kind of
lures her in he seems kind of nice is
he's playing it cool oh so yeah but
you're not and okay you didn't get me
benefits from pretending to be Native
American you're kind of like the
original Rachel Dolezal huh and she you
can see the fire in her eyes and then he
says you know she's a white woman
pretending to be black and Liz Warren
what can she say she said well look
that's that's what I was told by my
family and he goes uh-huh
and she goes uh-huh oh nothing more to
say this issue is not going away she has
tried to dismiss it she's tried to do
the the Clinton playbook which is you
have a scandal then you hide from the
scandal for six months and then someone
brings the scandal back up and you say
it's old news even though you never
answered any questions about it you can
say well it's old news I'm not gonna do
it this isn't working for Elizabeth
Warren she has had to answer for this
for years and years and years she has
tried every strategy unanswering it
she has doubled down she got the Boston
Globe which is her personal Pravda to do
a whole big expose Liz Warren took a DNA
test and she is Native American even
though it's only one one-thousandth and
probably not even that and she said see
look I'm Native American and she was
roundly mocked by everybody in both
parties since she got rid of that and
she said okay I'm sorry I didn't mean to
pretend that I was a Native American but
I never got any advantage from it and I
never
did it myself it was just Harvard
telling me telling people that I was a
Native American well then that wasn't
true cuz she signed her name is Native
American on a Texas bar application
okay that was she tries all these
different strategies none of them are
working if she wasn't able to come up
with an answer for this when she was
running against Scott Brown in the
Senate race she certainly should have
come up with an answer before she got
into the presidential race Trump has
called her Pocahontas for three years
she still didn't have an answer when she
got into the presidential race now so
much later she still doesn't have an
answer at the Breakfast Club asks her
about it she doesn't have an answer
she's not coming up with an answer the
issue is not going away and she's not
going anywhere
before we get to the next reason why
president Trump is probably likely to
get reelected I'd like to mention the
support for the Michael Nolt show comes
from our friends at rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans finding at the right house
is not easy let me tell you especially
in Los Angeles finding the right house
is not easy but finding the right
mortgage can be easy rocket mortgage is
doing more to help you understand the
home buying process so you can get
exactly what you need because it's not
just a mortgage it is your mortgage they
have found a better way I know a lot of
completely useless things I've spent
years and years and years accumulating
useless knowledge I have absolutely no
practical knowledge whatsoever which is
why Quicken Loans is great they're a
team of mortgage experts is obsessed
with finding a better way it means that
their number one goal is to make the
home buying process smoother for you
easier for you in fact rocket mortgages
there with award-winning client service
and support every step of the way
Quicken Loans has helped millions of
Americans to achieve their dream of
homeownership when you are ready to
purchase the home of your dreams they
can help you too and when you work with
them you get more than just a loan
because rocket mortgage is more than
just a lender get started online you
will not regret it at rocket mortgage
com / Knolls KO wles make it easy for
you
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states and MLS consumer access Dorgan
umber 30 30 rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans push button get mortgage so they
don't have any really strong candidates
on the Democrat side
Liz Warren is currently the surging
candidate
she's only surging because she hasn't
been in the public eye people basically
counted her out president Trump said a
few weeks ago she was done so then
people stopped paying attention to her
and she starts to surge then The
Breakfast Club points out that she's a
total fraud in her entire life as a lie
she's gonna fall down again Joe Biden is
is still a very high up in the polls
right now he's high up because nobody's
heard from him nobody's seen him when he
finally gets back out there was on a
debate stage he's gonna drop and maybe
he's got the best chance against Donald
Trump maybe Bernie sort of has a chance
against Donald Trump
maybe but where's the strong killer
candidate I just don't see them on that
side and that's the biggest issue
because elections are not only about the
economy they're not only about models
they're not about generic Republicans or
generic Democrats they're about real
people
maybe the Democrats could have won in
2016 but Hillary was a terrible
candidate maybe the Republicans could
have lost in 2016 but Trump was the
perfect candidate to beat Hillary that's
gonna be a major issue the other issue
is even let's say that first model is
correct the Allan Lichtman model and
they've got to impeach - to create more
scandal in the Trump administration and
hurt him in the election what are they
going to impeach over they that you had
Bob Muller come out and give his report
no collusion and he didn't make a
decision on obstruction but he said
there wasn't sufficient evidence then
Barr and the Attorney General William
Bar and Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein look at the evidence they
say we're there was absolutely not
sufficient evidence here then Muller
comes out and he says yeah but I didn't
exonerate him and Barr says yeah right
that's what I said in my letter -
nothing it just ends up with nothing so
we had Muller's press conference
yesterday pathetic and then William Barr
is not staying silent so the Attorney
General came out to respond to Muller's
criticisms we saw the Special Counsel
yesterday makes that statement he
analyzed eleven instances where there
were possible obstruction and then said
that he really couldn't make a decision
do you agree with that interpretation I
personally felt he could have reached
the decision in your view he could have
reached her conclusion right he could
have reached a conclusion
and the opinion says you cannot indict a
president while he's in office but he
could have reached a decision as to
whether it was criminal activity but he
had his reasons for not doing it which
he explained and I'm not going to you
know argue about those reasons but when
he didn't make a decision the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein and I
felt it was necessary for us as the
heads of the department to reach that
decision well I mean he seemed to
suggest yesterday that there was another
venue for this and that was Congress
well I'm not sure what he was suggesting
but you know the Department of Justice
doesn't use our powers of investigating
crimes as an adjunct to Congress so
William Bar is saying I'm not backing
down I'm not going away I behaved
absolutely appropriately and then the
interviewer on CBS brings up the
question of Muller's press conference
and what Muller said in his press
conference was bewildering he said we
investigated obstruction but we can't
come to a conclusion on obstruction
which raises the question why did he
investigate it then in the first place
actually that investigation exceeded his
bounds anyway because he was only tasked
with investigating Russian interference
in the 2016 election and then by saying
he couldn't come to a conclusion he's
sort of admitting that he overstepped
his bounds but then William bar says yes
he could have reached a conclusion
probably should have reached a
conclusion and what the interviewer then
says is well it looks like he was just
teeing it up for Congress he brought he
did that investigation to give Congress
a lot of ample fodder so that they could
begin impeachment proceedings and what
William bar says is he sort of tacitly
agrees with that and he says sure but
the DOJ does not exist to do
investigation work for Congress that's
not the role of the Department of
Justice so I think at the end of all of
this
the DOJ under William bar and ultimately
under President Trump
comes out looking a lot better than even
than the Muller team and by the way the
Muller team
more or less exonerated the president I
mean very practically speaking they did
exonerate the president even if in the
wording of the report they say they
won't reach a conclusion on the question
of obstruction so not a ton of scandal
here not a whole lot that is I think
really able to to gin up the impeachment
fury against Donald Trump Judge
Napolitano on Fox who I really like but
I think he's wrong here he comes out and
questions this questions attorney
general borne and basically defends Bob
Muller it's not uncommon for two
prosecutors looking at the same evidence
that come to different conclusions I
mean this happens every day in every
prosecutor's office but I think you hit
the nail on the head when you said it is
up to the Attorney General to make these
decisions I think the reason Muller did
not come to a conclusion on obstruction
of justice is not because the evidence
wasn't there it's there there are 10
crimes outlined is enough there to get
an indictment on any of them if the
defendant went out the President of the
United States I think the reason is
because he knew that the Attorney
General would never give him permission
to do so and he's a soldier he's a
marine he doesn't want to challenge and
take on his boss I think that the
argument breaks down there at the end so
what Napolitano is saying is there is a
ton of evidence that he could have been
used to indict if he weren't the
president of the United States however
Bob Muller is a loyal soldier and didn't
want to overstep his bounds that's
demonstrably not true Bob Muller has
contradicted his boss Attorney General
William bar multiple times in public
through that grandiose and ridiculous
letter he sent and then in that press
conference that was totally gratuitous
and unnecessary yesterday so he's
obviously willing to contradict attorney
general Barr and beyond that the point
Judge Napolitano is making is that he
didn't reach a conclusion because he he
felt it was overstepping his bounds
somehow he's a guy who already
overstepped his bounds well he didn't
reach a conclusion because he felt that
attorney general Barr
wouldn't act on it so what his job isn't
to just do whatever Attorney General bar
wants to do he could have easily put his
conclusions that Trump committed a crime
in that report and waited for the AG to
make his move
he's been combative already he staffed
the investigation with never Trump errs
I don't think that's why I think Mulder
was bloodthirsty to show evidence of a
crime and to come to a conclusion and he
just wasn't able to do it and so if you
had a weaker Attorney General if you had
an attorney general who was more
concerned about his own future political
career I think he would behave in a more
partisan way here but actually what's
happening is you have this guy William
Barr he's only the second guy in history
to serve as Attorney General twice and
William bar basically says look I have
nothing to lose and so I am going to
call it like it is I'm gonna be a
straight shooter and I'm gonna follow
DOJ protocol accused of protecting the
president and labeling the president
lying to Congress did you expect that
coming in well in a way I did expect it
yeah because I realize we live in a
crazy hyper partisan period of time and
I knew that it would only be a matter of
time if you if I was behaving
responsibly and calling them as I see
them that I'd be attacked because
nowadays people don't care about the
merits or the substance they only care
about who it helps you know who benefits
whether my side benefits or the other
side benefits everything is gauged by
politics and as I say that's
antithetical to the way the department
runs and any Attorney General and this
period is going to end up losing a lot
of political capital and I realized that
and that's one of the reasons that I
ultimately was persuaded that maybe I
should take it on because I I think at
my stage in life it really doesn't make
any difference really an admirable
statement here because he is so right
this guy has been in Washington for a
very long time he's operated there a
long time and he knows that anybody who
steps into that role if he has the most
unimpeachable record ever which William
bar basically does he if he steps into
that role right now
he is going to have his reputation
tarnished he is going to have his career
destroyed and barse basically saying I'm
at the end of my career so I can do it a
younger guy would not be able to do it
would not be able to withstand that
would have his career ruined would maybe
make questionable decisions to try to
save his career or save public face bar
doesn't need to worry about that he's
the most liberated man in Washington and
the only thing that they can hold over
him is his legacy is his reputation and
even on that he says who cares I'm at
the end of my career I've you know it
means a reputation that you've worked
your whole life on though yeah but
everyone dies and I'm not you know you
know I don't believe in the homeric idea
that you know immortality comes by you
know having odds on the maps you know
over the centuries you know so you don't
regret taking the job no that is the
right attitude not just for the Attorney
General but for every one of us
everybody dies just go for it just do
the right thing your life is not going
to be measured in the odds that are sung
to you after you die you can't just do
everything for public approval you just
just do it just go for it I love that
attitude that is an attitude of a very
dignified man and it's a great thing
that he is the Attorney General right
now we have got to get to a few more
fabulous stories the world's tiniest
baby was born and yet in many states in
this country that baby could be killed
and not just killed now could be killed
for many many more weeks we will get to
that we will get to the major fight on
the right between so Rob Amari at first
things and David French at National
Review and if we have time we'll get to
the steven crowder tweet storm that a
youtube right now is trying to deep
platform our pal Crowder will get to all
of that but first got to go to daily
wire calm it is 10 bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me at
the end reclaim and show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the amount wall
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag that is yesterday or next
Thursday you
questions backstage and you get most
importantly the leftist tears tumblr
[Music]
delish love them go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back with a lot more
the world's tiniest baby has been born
this is a wonderful so the baby weighs
basically nothing 23 weeks old born and
it has survived a wonderful feel-good
story obviously this raises some serious
questions about the abortion discussion
that we've been having for weeks
because in many states in this country
that baby could be killed and in many
states in this country people deny that
that baby is a baby but the baby was
born and the baby is now alive and
listen to how the mainstream media
covers it tonight an amazing
announcement from San Diego what doctors
are calling the world's tiniest
surviving baby just eight point six
ounces when she was born prematurely at
23 weeks well after five months in
intensive care the little girl named
Sadie is now healthy and she's headed
home and we are so happy for her family
eight point six ounces half a pound this
baby apparently was the size of an apple
born twenty three weeks now going home
happy healthy all alive good thing for
that baby that baby wasn't born in
Florida Massachusetts Nevada
Pennsylvania Rhode Island Arizona
California Connecticut Delaware Hawaii
Idaho Illinois Maine Maryland Michigan
Minnesota Montana New York Tennessee
Utah Washington Wyoming or Virginia to
parents who wanted to kill it because if
that had been the case she would be dead
she wouldn't even be admitted that she
was a baby
in all of those states in the country
you can kill babies who are at least as
old if not significantly older than that
baby
and those states want to pretend that
the baby isn't a baby but you just heard
him you just saw it the baby is a baby
this should end the abortion debate
those pictures should end the abortion
debate or at least what they should do
the abortion debate is take it in two
honest terms Naomi Wolf who were talking
about last week
Naomi wolf in the mid 90s came out and
said abortion rights mean
that we need to kill the baby in all of
its humanity in order to have equality
for men and women at least she was
honest what people who support abortion
at 23 weeks need to say is they look at
little baby Mabel was that her name look
at that little baby and say you should
die because of my political ideology my
political ideology means that you must
be killed that's just the cost of it
that's that's the end of the argument
that certainly should be the end of the
argument we'll see what those states do
on abortion something tells me they're
not going to be protecting babies
anytime soon there's a major fight
breaking out in the right right now and
the conservative movement in so much as
it still exists the fight is being
launched by a traditionalist
conservative writer named so Rob Amari
at the journal first things and he wrote
a piece called against David French ISM
you know David French David French very
nice guy he is a lawyer he served in
Iraq he is a writer at National Review
and he was a leading never Trump or Bill
Kristol tried to get him to run for
president he's one of the few remaining
never Trump errs Bill Kristol is another
one who's still remaining and what so
Rob is saying is that the conservative
movement in America needs to stop being
like David French and start being a
little tougher what this is really a
debate between is not these two guys I
mean the article is not called against
David French it's called against David
French ISM what this is really a debate
between is liberalism and traditionalism
conservatism and liberalism in America
are not opposite things in some ways
they are but in some ways they aren't
because what we mean by liberalism is
maybe classical liberalism you've heard
the phrase classical liberalism people
forget a lot that in the old days
liberalism had something to do with
Liberty now liberalism opposes Liberty
now it's all about equality but it comes
from the same place libertarians
liberalism classical liberalism and
there is a version of conservatism
that is really just a sort of
liberalism it accepts all the premises
of liberalism it just doesn't take them
as far as the progressives do and then
there's an alternative to this which is
tradition actual conservatism so so Rob
identifies David French as the
embodiment of a conservative movement
frozen in time as the embodiment of a
conservative movement that is trying and
Akron is tickly to cut-and-paste
solutions and attitudes of the 1980s of
the Reagan Revolution into the Trump era
as a movement that has not caught up
with the times that has not accepted the
changing circumstances of the world that
has not admitted its own failures there
were many great things that happened
during the Reagan era but it wasn't
perfect and in politics you've got to
adapt you've got to acknowledge your own
flaws and change them and try to fix
them so he writes so Rob writes what is
David French ISM is Irving Kristol set
of neoconservatism French ISM is more a
persuasion or a sensibility than a
movement with clear tenets fair enough
that's true the the reaction to this
though is that that's also true of the
kind of conservatism that so Rob is is
advocating it's true this idea that
conservatism is more a persuasion or an
attitude than it is a clear ideological
movement I think that's true of all
sorts of conservatism it's certainly
true of the traditional conservatism
that I think about it's a little bit
more of an inclination it's a little bit
more of an intuition as the conservative
philosopher Russell Kirk said but fair
enough point David Fran Chisholm is so
Rob defines that the key here is that it
exalts individual autonomy above all
else individual liberty above all else
and David French ISM according to so Rob
says that the primary if not the sole
aim of government is to maximize
individual autonomy and the the argument
for maximizing individual autonomy is
that on the one hand it's true you'll
get a lot of decadence and you'll get
porn and you'll get cultural rot but you
will also then carve out a space in the
culture
religious conservatives to practice
virtue and to do what they want to do
now the objection to that version the
David French version of conservatism
which is just a an older version of
liberalism is that true Liberty cannot
survive the sort of libertinism and
decadence that follows from maximizing
individual liberty so the the objection
to David French ISM is that if you just
maximize individual liberty and you say
okay you're going to have your space to
be decadent pagan degenerates and we're
going to have our space to be religious
conservatives eventually that that
maximizing of individual liberty will
create a libertine culture that will not
tolerate the religious conservatives and
we're certainly seeing this in the
culture today we're seeing obviously
prayer in schools has not existed for
over 50 years that was rooted out we're
now being told that if you object to gay
marriage even that you're some sort of
bigot the redefinition of marriage if
you object to curious sexualities you're
some sort of bigot if you object you are
no longer tolerated your deep platformed
your censored your kicked out your your
not allowed in the culture same thing
with a good analysis of they're a good
analogy rather would be drugs or porn so
the idea being let's legalize all drugs
and if you want to do drugs you can do
drugs and if you don't want to do drugs
you don't have to do drugs and it'll be
fine that's a totally neutral culture
except that isn't neutral because drugs
take away your Liberty so when you do
drugs in the name of Liberty the drugs
enslave you you lose some of your
individual autonomy you become addicted
you become a slave to the drug and so
what you were doing initially in the
name of Liberty totally erodes your
Liberty same thing with porn in our
culture there a zillion men in this
country who are addicted to online
pornography and you the argument for
porn is that everybody should have their
maximum individual liberty but then the
argument against foreign is it takes
away everybody's Liberty because it
takes away your it because it enslaves
you so on the one hand you've got this
conservatism this traditional
conservatism that's so Rob is writing
about
and that says that society should
primarily be focused on the good on
virtue on good stuff on the other hand
you have the classical liberalism that
he calls David French ISM which says
that society should primarily value
Liberty not just as a means to the good
or to virtue but as the good unto itself
and this is a big difference I for one I
love Liberty a few people love Liberty
more than I do but I like Liberty
because it is an instrument to the good
Liberty isn't the be-all and end-all if
some guy uses his Liberty to do a bunch
of drugs and waste his life that's
terrible that's an awful abuse of
Liberty Liberty has to be geared towards
something which is the good so Rob
writes only The Libertines take the
logic of maximal autonomy the one that
French shares to its logical terminus
they say in effect for us to feel fully
autonomous you must positively affirm
our sexual choices or transgression our
power to disfigure our natural bodies
and redefine what it means to be human
and your disapprobation makes us feel
less than fully autonomous so one
example of individual autonomy that so
Rob actually cites is a drag queen
reading session at a public library we
talked about this about a week ago some
public library they have a drag queen
reading session for little kids now this
is obviously an example of maximizing
individual liberty the drag queen gets
to dress however he wants to he gets to
show up and read at this library the
parents can choose to take their kids
there that's all it's all just
individual liberty it's horrific and
should not happen but it's that's just
individual liberty the issue that so Rob
identifies is the only way to sustain
drag queen reading sessions and
libraries is with some level of moral
approval by the community if the if the
community didn't approve of the drag
queen reading session it would not be
permitted to happen so when you open
this whole door to maximizing individual
liberty as much as you want you end up
getting drag queen reading sessions and
then you in the community are complicit
in the moral
you're seeing this around the culture
and now if you don't approve of drag
queens
if you don't approve of certain sexual
relationships you are it's not you are
not just told okay you do you I'll do me
it live and let live you're told you're
a bigot you're you're should be
ostracized from society it is not just
neutral to maximize individual autonomy
it is normative it has moral
consequences it changes how the
community views morality and ultimately
it becomes hostile to the traditional
choices that people might use their
individual liberty to choose so you say
okay it's just a big open neutral
playing field you can make your crazy
wacko radical choice we'll make our
traditional choices ultimately the wacko
choices will overpower the traditional
ones and a good example of this is
religious liberty religious liberties so
that was established in this country to
protect all the various sects of
Christianity from hating each other and
warring with each other no one ever
expected religious liberty to be used as
an argument for taking down a statue of
the ten commandments at a courthouse or
at a State Capitol no one ever expected
that likewise no one ever expected it to
be used as an argument to put up a
statue of Satan at a courthouse or a
State Capitol as the American atheists
are trying to do and have been trying to
do for decades no one ever expected
religious liberty to be maximized in
that individual way because let's take
it to its most absurd extreme let's say
someone was a religious devotee of
Hitler they think Hitler's a god they're
hip Hitler Hitler rights and they
worship Adolf Hitler does that mean that
we should be forced to build statues of
swastikas at public courts or at at
public state houses it's not just a
political statement they worship Hitler
as a religion there's the religion of
the Hitlerites should we be permitted to
do that no no one would say that so why
would we have a statue of Satan it's
because people get this backwards
religious liberty to taken to its
extreme is incoherent because Liberty
relies on religious ideas our idea of
Liberty presupposes certain religious
foundations other
cases in the world don't have religious
liberty like we do why because they
don't come from the same religious
culture that we come from the idea of
liberty that we have comes from
Christianity the religion in religious
liberty comes before the Liberty so a
Liberty that undermines that religion is
totally incoherent now we're getting
this debate really in a little into the
weeds but the reason we have this debate
at all between the traditionalists and
the classical liberals is because during
the Cold War
individualists s-- and traditionalists
came together against the Soviet Union
and the traditionalists opposed the
Soviet Union because it was atheistic
and the classical liberals and
libertarians opposed the Soviet Union
because it was communist and
collectivistic I'm simplifying a little
bit but you had the cultural guys were
upset about the cultural questions the
economic guys were upset about the
economic questions and so they joined
together in something called fusion ISM
which William F Buckley Jr started
basically after the the Second World War
after we won the Cold War
this debate opened up between the
traditionalists and the classical
liberals and 2016 blew that that debate
wide open in particular this is an
extraordinarily important debate to have
it's important that conservatives of all
stripes have this debate but the very
important thing for David French for so
Rob Amari and for everyone in it we have
to not engage in the debate by
alienating each other because the the
conservative the conservative coalition
such as it is will be destroyed and
leftism will too will take over if we
allow this to totally crack us apart i
side with so rub on this question in so
much as we should keep things in their
proper place in so much as we should
pursue good and not just Liberty for its
own sake we also must defeat the left
and we are debating right now how best
to defeat the left and what it means to
defeat the left but we certainly
shouldn't alienate permanently our
allies and our potential allies for this
very quickly i have to get to steven
crowder Steve Crowder is being targeted
by some wack
schmuck at voxcom who is trying to get
his channel taken off the air he's
getting the channel taken off the air
because he says steven crowder was mean
to him and steven crowder
used it was making fun of his sexual
preferences and therefore he should lose
his gigantic youtube channel
what did steven crowder say about this
guy Carlos maza here's what he said we
get to the video with our favorite
favorite and listen right it's
ridiculous it's bonkers you're being
given a free pass as a crappy writer
because you're gay that's Federline it
is a little queer graph there now the
graph is queerness violence Phil okay so
the little query could eat his chips all
nonchalantly it's code for Ray mister
we're eating chess on the box this is
what mr. gay Vox wants to do mister
let's be queer from Vox what were you
holding gay Lotito from Potts movement
fast motion is gay now we're here with
the short hair lesbian I'm Skye is
hiding in a closet
two weeks later probably along to his
next Pride Parade out but this guy on
the gay semi Latino vote this spray
tomorrow okay he's a sachets across
without eight like just stop Doug a box
Friday is wrong now he could be a [ __ ]
your honor but how many lispy angry
sprites and Vox you by the way the gay
Mexican guy gay latino v-neck gay
Mexican Mexican gay guy used to work
Mexican gay latino there at the voxel
gay latino from baki
token box gay atheist sprite with
surprisingly surprisingly flaccid chest
considering how thin he is it is very
bizarre to me okay so steven crowder you
never left will not let one joke go
without you know just really taking it
to its extreme so he's calling this guy
a bunch of names and he's making fun of
them
this guy Carlos maza it deserves a lot
of criticism and should be made fun of I
think what he's misunderstanding here
though is that this guy thinks that
steven crowder is calling him queer
because crowder hates gay people
which is not the case steven crowder is
calling this guy queer because steven
crowder doesn't like him and he's
calling him queer because that's one way
among others to make fun of him it would
be like with me if some guy comes up to
me and says hey Knowles you're a [ __ ]
Guido [ __ ] I don't
he wouldn't say that because he hates
Italian people probably he would say
that cuz he doesn't like me and I am of
Italian descent and so one way to make
fun of me is to call me a bunch of slurs
for Italians that's what's actually
going on here that's what he doesn't get
if this guy just went on at 5,000 tweets
- I don't have time to go through all
the tweets but he just exemplifies the
worst parts of the whiney left here so
I'll go through a few Carlos mozzie says
so I have pretty thick skin when it
comes to online harassment but something
has been really bothering me when you
say I have thick skin but what that
means is you don't have thick skin so he
you know you're in for just a huge wine
fest he says since I started working at
Vox crowder has been making video after
video debunking my videos every single
video has included repeated overt
attacks on my sexual orientation and
ethnicity such as that okay okay fine
yeah you're right
steven crowder made gay jokes about you
how many times does the left insult
straight white men how many times does
the left talk about how awful straight
white men are I mean it's become a
cliche to say straight white man the
left is also insulting people by
referring to their sexual preferences
the left does exactly what you are
observing crowder doing he goes on I've
been called an anchor baby let's be
queer a Mexican all this sort of all
these sort of names I wake up to a wall
of abuse on Instagram and Twitter
I was doxed it scared me they make me
the target of harassment it makes life
miserable I waste a lot of time blocking
abusive crowder fanboys and this derails
your mental health dude everybody in
public life gets hate mail everybody I
get a zillion messages the threatening
message is mean messages and salting
messages do you know what I do I ignore
them because I'm an adult and sticks and
stones may break my bones but words will
never hurt me
if you think that getting hate mail
derails your mental health get a new
profession go work in some like private
accounting office somewhere far far from
the public I don't be in the public eye
people in the public eye have always and
will always get hate mail grow up
goodness gracious
and this is what they do they say it
derails your mental health is a way of
trying to claim that they're really
victims they're not just regular victims
they are super special victims as though
the rest of us don't get hate mail
everybody in public gets hate mail that
said I'm not mad at Crowder there will
always be monstrous in the world I'm
just angry at YouTube for not banning it
okay you're not mad at Krannert you just
want him to be completely silenced this
has been going on for years and
Crowder's still not banned all of this
to say I work my effing back off to
create smart thorough engaging content
for YouTube a company that claims to
give an s about LGBT creators and it's
miserable to have that same company
helping facilitate a mind-melting amount
of direct harassment oh you make youtube
videos and you don't want to get
negative comments every YouTube video is
filled with abusive mean comments that
is the definition of a YouTube video but
you think because you're really special
and you make really good videos so you
shouldn't get any mean comments all the
rest of us get mean but no you because
you're so special you shouldn't get any
mean comments grow up dude
oh my gosh my family sees this Yeah
right if you're in public your family
sees everything
yeah they see how people react to you
and they see what you do that's what
being in public is your family is part
of the public
this isn't about silencing conservative
it's about enforcing an anti-harassment
policy I'm sorry he said but it's about
enforcing an anti-harassment policy when
you say but you negate what you've said
before it so then he tells people to go
over in flag Crowder's videos by the way
sure would be a shame if someone went
over and flagged his videos how his
name's Carlos Mazda sure would be a
shame they shouldn't do that
and then he goes on and says YouTube
does not give an F about queer creators
YouTube does not give an F about
marginalized creators YouTube does not
give an F about diversity or inclusion
first of all nobody is more marginalized
on YouTube than
servants or on social media generally
second of all nobody is a greater
example of diversity on social media
than conservatives that is the diversity
right now you have homogeneity when you
add another point of view you have
diversity Wow Wow what he's saying is if
you are not totally in agreement with me
if you ever would criticize my thoughts
or ideas or how I behave you are a
horrible bigot that is what the left
does they're going for crowder now some
people are gonna want to abandon Crowder
because they themselves would never make
a gay joke of course not you you are
lily-white you're like the newly fallen
snow but because you would never make a
gay joke you won't defend Crowder
Crowder is just very prominent and
they're going after him because they
haven't come around to going after you
yet it's outrageous this guy should be
ashamed of himself and we stand with
Stephen Crowder
all right that's our show we got a lot
more but too bad we'll get to it on
Monday in the meantime I'm Michael nose
this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you that
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkiss and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today you know I've been
called racist because I did a segment on
the show yesterday discussing some very
troubling accusations about Martin
Luther King jr. so I want to address
that claim today also the HBO series
Chernobyl is a damning indictment of
socialism but the left says that no it's
actually more about Donald Trump so
we'll try to try to figure it is it
about Donald Trump is it about socialism
and old town road is quite possibly the
worst song ever recorded but it's a huge
hit everyone seems to like it is
everyone just pretending to like it as
some kind of joke but we'll try to get
to the bottom of that today
on the Matt Walsh show